foreign
[Music]
it's Wednesday night and I just sat down
at my Mom's bar sneakers
I can hear the band doing their sound
check and I take a bite of my buffalo
chicken and I look across the bar and
see my mom sit down next to a regular
she strikes up a conversation with them
and introduces them to my neighbor
sitting a few seats down
I've witnessed this so many times at
sneakers that
it's become commonplace to me
but lately probably the last year or so
I've thought a lot about the community
building that she's done
so naturally the past 38 years
and when I say growing up in a
restaurant
I really mean that this is my baby
picture on the bar there at sneakers
but jumping ahead
I'd say just about 30 years from there I
am now our manager of our professional
community at rstudio
so in my role I get to work with a lot
of you all
either in the room or watching virtually
and help connect customers to be able to
share use cases and best practices
and teach lessons learned with one
another
in doing so I've learned that a lot of
what makes us really good at our job
is not what's apparent in our resume or
through our prior job experience
or through the degree that we have
so when I think about my role in
organizing and building community at our
studio
I realize I've been running my own bar
therefore well there's so many things
that you can learn from restaurant
experience itself but there are four key
takeaways that I want to share with you
all today
that you can take in building
communities of your own or
growing communities of your own
so the first one
find your taco Tuesday
or be consistent
at sneakers and at a lot of restaurants
I'm sure we know
there are certain days that are often
associated with certain foods
or certain days that
are associated with certain events
at Sneakers this could be
having tacos on Tuesday or live music on
Wednesday and Saturday
and people don't come to every single
event but when they have a free night
or when they're looking for something to
do with friends they know exactly where
they can go
and so I try to do this with our events
at our studio as well
so every Tuesday at 12 eastern time I
host the r Studio Enterprise Community
Meetup
and this is a meet-up event for people
to just share what they're doing
so they may share a new use case or a
best practice learn and present for 30
minutes
and take questions from the community
and so these happen every Tuesday at 12
Eastern Time
and it may be people gathering around a
an industry group like using R in
healthcare
or more broadly using shiny in
production
also every Thursday at 12 eastern time I
host our data science Hangout
which I see a few people here who have
been to those as well
this is a little bit
less formal not that the other is formal
out either but there's no presentation
at these
it's just a different data science
leader from the community
who joins me to answer questions from
the community
and so all the questions are audience
LED from you all and could be questions
like
how do I talk to executives
or how are you thinking about hiring
right now
should I have a centralized or
decentralized data science team
these are every Thursday at 12 Eastern
Time
I've included the link to the calendar
for these if you ever want to add the
individual events or just the whole
series of events to your calendar
this one's best formatted for your phone
but if you're on your desktop add an
extra Dash and type calendar and it will
look a lot nicer too
but if you're also an organizer I just
wanted to include that the tool that I
use here is called add event
I really like that it makes it really
easy to share events that people can
just put on their calendar without
having to give me any information so
find your taco Tuesday
secondly start conversations across the
bar
so
as I opened up with that scene
imagine the regular sitting alone at the
bar my mom might walk over to them and
strike up a conversation with them and
the couple sitting a few seats down
it might be about the band that's
playing next week that she knows that
they both like or it could be about a
special that's on the menu that somebody
else ordered across the bar too
the topic itself doesn't really matter
as much
it's just that she's giving permission
for that interaction to happen
and kicking off the conversation
she might start the conversation and
then have to go walk away and run to the
kitchen and help with something or make
a drink behind the bar
but that person sitting alone at the bar
might stay a little bit longer because
they now know somebody
or they might come back more regularly
because they feel a part of the sneakers
community
I think one of the sneakers regulars
said it best and this is a newspaper
article from a few years ago
but Deb is someone who I've known for
many years now she's filmed employee
wedding she actually made a video for my
high school volleyball team but Doug
said it's the kind of place where you
can go in alone
have some food and a glass of wine and
pretty soon you are a part of the
conversation
I want people to feel this way
at our studio community events as well
minus the food and wine except for this
week
but as Community organizers we have a
responsibility to bring people together
based on shared interests
and I think it's important here that
these interests aren't something that we
ourselves have to be experts on
but we can go a step further here
to help kick off conversations with
people at events as well
I think one of my favorite examples of
this
comes from the data science hangout
which happens every Thursday at 12
Eastern Time
but this particular week featured
Christy angel
a data science manager from Stitch fix
and leading up to
that session
a few people had reached out to me on
LinkedIn or maybe at meetups as well
I mentioned that they're really having a
hard time finding a new job
and they were hitting roadblocks with
recruiters and not getting through to a
hiring manager because they didn't have
a certain degree
and so I had the privilege of of knowing
this because as the organizer of the
group and getting to talk with all these
people
so I was able to ask this to Christy for
them anonymously
just to get her insights and and hear
her experience
and I started to see in the chat that
everybody started commenting with their
own degrees
and their own non-data Science degrees
in a room full of data scientists or
Zoom room full of data scientists
and it was
just one of those moments that
you just remember
just seeing people all supporting each
other and
like cheering each other on for their
non-data Science degrees and and
supporting people who are running into
this right now
so start those conversations across the
bar
third
touch every table
so I had sneakers
it's pretty much a guarantee if you go
in for dinner
my mom will come by your table and thank
you for coming in
if it's her night to work of course if
it's her business partner Annie's time
night to work she'll be the one to come
by
and it doesn't matter if you are a
regular or this is your first time
coming into sneakers
they'll stop by and
say thank you for coming in and ask
where you're from how you're enjoying
your meal
or maybe reminiscing with customers who
have become like family
I actually had no idea this was a term
until
preparing for this talk but table
touching is a real thing in the
restaurant industry
and there's a lot of articles about how
going touching every table can help
create a guest for life
in the virtual world I want to be able
to stop by and and meet you at your
table as well
the way that I like to do this is when
people join a Meetup or a data science
Hangout
is to write down the names of
people who mentioned they're joining for
the very first time
or
maybe it's just a name that I haven't
seen joined before
but also write down a few names of
people who have been coming back
regularly or names that are faces that
I've been seeing on on Zoom
this is not possible I know with
hundreds of people but I don't think
that's a reason to not do it at all
so I may say to my oops how am I saying
to myself
today I'm going to write down the names
of five regulars
and five new people
and I'll reach out to them on LinkedIn
just to say thank you thank you for
joining or thank you for the comment
that you put into the chat
so it might be just a few people that
week but hopefully as we go I get to
reach out to to everybody
so touch every table
and the last takeaway I want to leave
you with
which also expands on the last last one
sometimes when you're going by and
visiting with a table
you get a chance to learn more about
someone's experience and how you can
make that a little bit better
but not only in what they're telling you
but in observing the unsaid
so I think I've given you enough
restaurant examples right now that I can
put you in the role of owner
so let's say
over here we have our table of four
who are waiting for trivia night to
start
they all ordered a round of drinks three
of them are finishing up
and you walk by their table to check in
on them
you notice though that one of the drinks
is pushed over to the side
now you ask them how their night's going
they say everything's great but you can
tell they probably didn't enjoy
their drink as much as they would have
like do by the way that it's pushed over
to the side
so you look at that and take it as an
opportunity to ask them if there's
something else that you could get them
and insist that you want them to have
something that they'd enjoy
this doesn't have to just be about
untouched food or drinks it could also
be about
stopping by a table and noticing that
it's somebody's birthday and
and noticing that before they actually
told you
so just noticing the little things
this dining experience looks a little
bit different in a virtual world
so let me just take you on a journey
here so we'll look at my
um
this little stick figure here and we can
imagine it as anyone but we'll call him
Bob
so Bob joins a meet-up event for the
first time and listens in
maybe Bob was on the list of one of the
five people that I wrote down as a new
person or maybe he wasn't
he comes back again and
joins in listen only mode again
a week later he comments in the chat
and then I noticed Bob unmute briefly it
pops up to the top of my zoom
but doesn't end up speaking
so I am not going to say to Bob on
LinkedIn hey you joined three times and
you never talk what can I do to make you
feel more comfortable
but I might say something like
hey Bob thanks so much for joining today
I loved your comment about learning r as
a SAS user I think that perspective was
incredibly helpful
if you ever have any suggestions
or things that we could be doing to make
this event more useful please let me
know
and Bob might say thanks for joining I
had a great time I wanted to ask a
question but
I wasn't sure if it was the right format
and so
I've had the opportunity now to learn
something more about Bob's experience by
thanking him for coming and by just
noticing
that there was something there in the
unsaid
and so what Bob does for me here is I
have that opportunity to say
did you oh gosh this is there we go
um did you know that you can ask
questions anonymously as well
and so
I can let him know this is a place for
any question to be to be asked but
there's something more there it points
out to me that I didn't make it clear
maybe in the beginning of the the
presentation
that people could ask questions
anonymously
and if I said that
once maybe that's not enough because if
somebody joined a few minutes later they
would have missed that
so it lets me know that that's something
I should put in the chat as well
so months later maybe he keeps coming
back
and keeps joining
and eventually presents at the Meetup as
well
I think this is one of my favorite
things about Community Building
is seeing somebody come for the very
first time
and then starting to get to know people
and you see them like being friends on
Twitter or commenting on each other's
LinkedIn posts
and then eventually that person being
the one presenting at the event too
so today I've given you four key
takeaways
that I've learned from growing up at
sneakers
but there are so many more tips out
there from amazing Community Builders
and Community organizers like you all
I know there's so many here in the
audience today at the conference and
watching virtually as well
so I wanted to take this opportunity to
share this Resource as well
a few months ago I guess it's not that
new now a few months ago
I
helped build the site rstudio.com
champion
and it was designed to help people
advocate for data science at their own
organizations
and when they're facing roadblocks to
have a place to go
but also included a section on Community
Building
and this includes a lot of
knowledge and resources from amazing
Community Builders out there
and people that I've met at at other
events
there's also a feedback form on the very
bottom of this site if you scroll to it
where you can share your own tips and
tricks
or ask to see something else that's
maybe not there yet
I just want to say thank you so much to
all of you for for being here today and
it's amazing to see you all at the the
conference too
I want to say a big thank you to my mom
Rhonda Dempsey who I learned so much
from and continue to learn so much from
also a huge congrats to her and her
business partner Annie who are
celebrating 38 years in business at
Sneakers Cafe this week
and also feel like in case my mom and
dad were watching to say happy
anniversary to them too because today is
their actual anniversary
but just like sneakers would not be the
same without their community
our and our studio
and soon to be posit would definitely
not be the same without all of you
thank you so much again for being here
if you have any questions I'd love to
hear them but I'd also put my LinkedIn
and Twitter up on the screen as well
because I would love to connect there
LinkedIn is probably the preference
I'll also take questions on the Discord
Channel communities of practice too
thank you everybody
thank you
[Music]